why is that even beautiful women bad
[ __ ] are single today it's simple
feminism feminism taught you one that
you're a queen you guys give to this
earth you're the prize no [ __ ] you ain't
no you ain't you ain't a queen you ain't
never gonna be my queen because you
ain't my mother you don't love me
unconditionally you love me under
conditions your mom is your queen no
she's not
is your dad your kink
hi king could i get my life
bro
that don't work for me no
no you don't want to ask your kids for
permission to go out just to disclaimer
i'm a heterosexual male but i know
myself and i know my boys and i know how
we rock and i know what would keep me
what me would want to keep a woman
around long term so if i was a woman in
2021 and moving forward how i would keep
a man with money looks or status is so
simple the first thing i would do is
allow the man to lead say for instance
he was like yo babe i'm gonna pick you
up at five o'clock we're gonna go here
at this time get ready i will let him do
that because that would show me that he
has the right qualities i'm looking for
long term provide protect and lead the
number two thing i would do is i'll be
considerate so if he's hungry or if his
room's dirty his house is dirty i clean
it and cook for him because that will
show him that i'm a supportive woman
which is very important long term so ron
i would make way to like the second or
third day and when we do establish the
fun i would do it every day and i would
have him wrapped around my fingers and i
really don't understand how y'all having
these problems it is so easy
can we have it in
between can we have a in between that
the in between is not possible
i think the in between is lovely
yeah when i'm out playing playstation
my girl gets up and she makes me a
sandwich
because whenever she needs a coffee
imma make her a coffee
she cooks
i cook
can we have it in between can we can we
no
it's always yeah i bring the money my
girl bring money too i bring the money
can't she bring the money i bring the
money
she cook i cook she needs something
clean she yo can you clean that i'm like
i'm sorry let me clean that and she
cleaned can can we can we can no
no it's i mean i understand i understand
where all that is from i understand
where it's from but i don't know in
between's not possible
it's not nah a man never makes a meal
[ __ ]
okay
oh okay
but can we just have a little be
considerate it's like brother you're not
going to be considerate as well i don't
know
like
you know what i'm saying like no man i
don't know man in between just in
between just a little yeah no a lot of
you guys are feeding into your own
perpetual failures in life and then
getting mad at the market and [ __ ]
on it women do it as well i find it
fascinating everyone's always blaming
everybody else
men nowadays women nowadays no some of
y'all just need to do some self work and
figure your [ __ ] out and it's a lot
easier to say to women and even women do
this when we get on their tv shows and
be like what's wrong with men today why
don't they have their [ __ ] together
because we're going through some [ __ ] we
are
and guess what ladies you going through
some [ __ ] too
you are yeah you finding out that sexual
liberation isn't always wonderful nope
that just being out here [ __ ] around
and doing all this stuff that you guys
now can do with thanks to birth control
and all that stuff isn't all that great
for your emotional state we're finding
out this shit's weird but i'm just so
sick everywhere i'll be like oh the the
other gender no you as an individual got
to figure out you know like jordan peter
says clear your room yeah do you say
that before you go to try to fix the
genders [ __ ] clean your room
yeah clean your room and i know people
said that's banal advice such as clean
nose i'm promising you a lot of y'all
got some [ __ ] y'all gotta sort out your
own lives before you sit down here
talking about the modern women or the
modern man or all this other [ __ ] no
[ __ ] clean your room the problem is
that i'm a man i'm a leader i'm the
toxic [ __ ] guy the tool right because
when we go out right you expect me to
take care of you right when we go out i
pay for you good we go to the store here
hey get some shoes you good i got you
but when i tell you to do something do
it
that's the problem don't expect me to
chase you and beg you and get on my
knees bro i'm not submissive i'm
dominant and then what happens is i
don't want to beat that he's he's
talking he's bad your friends tell you
he's a bad guy right then you go be with
the nice guy and you end up cheating on
him or leaving him because he's weak he
don't make you feel nothing you know he
don't blow the back
that's the problem you're the problem
you're delusional i'm pretty sure that
the the the delusion and
too much expectation
that's definitely a part of that yeah
i've seen some girl
on tick tock the other day crying about
the fact that oh my god i've wasted my
time and she just realizes that [ __ ] i
wasted my time i've been like on this
and ain't no man going to end it and
then you end up alone i don't want to i
don't want necessarily someone that nags
someone that's always like reminding me
that how you go in a relationship with
someone that reminds you i don't need
you i'm strong i'm a strong woman
i don't need you
they don't need me over there then okay
like that's the basis of your
relationship i don't need you that's
that's how we that's how we start that's
ground zero i don't need you i don't
need you
i don't need you for these videos
i only and i can what
yeah
he don't need me either but it would be
some other [ __ ] you know what i mean
imagine that every day i would remind
you that
that's not fun on the point focus on
what the [ __ ] you bring to the table i
guess
make it work yeah thanks for the ideas
for the editing i'm not gonna focus i
don't need the [ __ ] is that snagging but
there's some people to focus on that
that's how they go out about things
that's how they want to go fish
sway
so i understand what he's saying but you
know one thing i've noticed like there's
a lot of people all of a sudden become
dating coaches
they start selling seminars and doing
all this stuff and
it's very lucrative
it was very lucrative to come onto the
scene and then have products you can
sell to people who are looking for
answers
and these [ __ ] come out the
woodwork and some of them got no game i
know you ain't got none of that time you
just believe in your crimes yeah
but because these people don't know
they're they're buying into the whole
fake funk even this guy talking about
like i'm an alpha dog i'm an alpha male
it's like this [ __ ] lives in his mom's
basement
he does yeah oh that's funny
yeah
oh wow it's like breath
what you talking about that's weird yeah
it's one of those things where
everyone's trying to project that yeah
dating coach market is is full of yup
full of cringing you know that's why me
personally
i don't watch a lot of that content i
just take it as entertainment generally
speaking but i understand the need for a
lot of folks because a lot of people
don't know what they're doing well just
know there's a lot of snake oil salesmen
if i'd done did everybody on the block
you should still love me
because i'm a high value woman
i'm a bad bee
oh i i bet so you want me to provide and
take care of you all right can you at
least you know cook and clean for me
you can cook clean for yourself aren't
you mean
i mean you want me to provide and take
care of you cause you're a man that's
your job
i will if you want me to lead and
provide for you and take care of the
family can you at least do what i tell
you to do
not your slave you narcissist you abuse
a
i i man heard a couple of people say
stuff like that so i understand where
it's from so i'm saying i understand
where it's from and why why he says that
it kills me that dudes who live in their
mom's basements talk about
depending and being dependable it's like
breath
a lot of dudes
feel like they don't get to be a man in
the relationship but also aren't ready
to take on that traditional man role
that they
want yeah
you know what i mean some of you have
not taken control of your lives some of
you have not
assumed your own characters true your
own responsibilities this guy's a prime
example he's out here lecturing the
world about this and that [ __ ] you live
in your mom's basement and i say this
not to like [ __ ] on [ __ ] that just
understand sometimes financially is not
there but don't be out here talking
about alpha dog alpha dog mom's like uh
stephen it's in the microwave what
come on bro but that's a queen he lives
in the kingdom
maybe
i think it's also like
just the way i think about stuff but at
17 i was outside of my parents place had
my own spot working full-time trying to
sue my responsibilities like a lot of
you [ __ ] got to do that if you
wanted to have this whole traditional
role as well it can't just be the other
side of the aisle you guys can't just
say feminism feminism what about y'all
because if i'm being honest with you a
lot of you are not ready to assume the
responsibility of a family i am out of
there all right so we you got to balance
it out and that's why i mean when i say
this dating market for dating coaches is
extra cringe it's like y'all don't
practice what you preach y'all fronting
out here and it sounds great because
you've repeated what other people said
but you're not living by those
principles it's like the pastor who just
reads the bible out [ __ ] little boys
it's a little weird it's a little weird
it's big weird it's also illegal